and we should tell the story about how I
rummage to get your sweater and you know
I've told I still have that I haven't I
haven't Pam sent me the the rich sweater
from lucky Louie no this disgusting you
don't understand like I we we okay Rick
Shapiro uh-huh and Jim Norton and I like
all of a sudden they waited nine months
the amount of time it takes to gestate a
baby and create one episode of king of
the hill they waited that amount of time
to tell us
we weren't picked up that's right lucky
Louie I remember walking with Louie on
like 6th Avenue at him going we still
don't we still have one more shot they
see it talked to Robert rule who it said
it took them a long time to find out and
they were doing so she would call each
other
Jim would call me ago hey what do you
think what do you think you think we're
gonna get picked up and I'm like oh [ __ ]
I think so I don't think so
I don't know and then when it got to be
like seven months eight months nine
months it would be kind of rude at this
point if they didn't pick us up right
right so then they didn't [ __ ] pick
us up and so I was like where's all our
[ __ ] like you know Kim and Louie
we had wedding rings on the show I had a
pair of glasses that that like this
optician made for me my that red leather
jacket uh-huh there's this sweater yeah
Jimmy you know Jim wore that thing
sweater gross brown sweater he seen but
one everything my god who's finding
these that that's killing me yeah and um
also didn't you wear a thing on your
foot like an orthopedic oh I got that
was for real I hurt myself for real that
was a legit that wasn't a character
choice that was Jim Norton stepped into
a whole walking process because you have
foot thing on your foot on my foot
that's right that was back then but I
went oh I still have that mc5 shirt but
I went into the storage space because
they said we just threw it into storage
and now it's like in general population
I'm like Jesus this [ __ ] should be
the Smithsonian Institution you loved
that show I loved I loved that show yeah
but I predicted it predicted I said this
show is amazing you know they always
they said that we put canned laughs in
never they had to turn it down
people went [ __ ] crazy in the studio
and I remember you said it's like it's
like they took a crack house they they
emptied it out into a bus and they
brought everybody here sometimes we
would have the craziest audiences and
they'd be talking to us had never air of
course they were all learning about all
of us in the in that moment and they
still respect telling you it was like
the the you know those old they would do
like Barn Theatre with like Mickey
Rooney and like all of that it felt like
that and as somebody who's been acting
since you're a little kid are you
sitting around going like this doesn't
happen guys it was I'm telling you it's
still I love talking about it because it
was such a singular time he did two
shows on Friday nights that's right with
the tape we did we should tape Thursday
and Friday and then they condensed it to
that's right or we did two shows in a
row it was it was nuts yeah we were we
we started on Monday we were off-book on
our feet taping on Thursdays and it was
just electric it was electric so laughs
in that studio you know that I remember
one guy criticized that a canned
laughter the laughter is too loud and
I'm like there was Lois wouldn't Lee
called he explained the whole sweetening
process of laughter yeah and how they
sweeten it on every sitcom you've ever
seen and he wouldn't permit it he would
not allow them to sweeten the laughs oh
no
so the joke's on you have to turn it
down because you couldn't hear and
everybody's like that's so [ __ ] fake
and it was 90 percent so what was it
that you predicted I knew that it was
going to be something and be meaningful
I knew it was going to
make a mark but it would be like a blip
on the radar I knew we were too soon
that's what I was gonna say because it's
one of those shows that like what's
unfair about it and somebody who wasn't
on it but just watched it like when you
put the DVDs in now and just watch it
back you're like holy [ __ ] like what why
wouldn't this show have gotten picked up
Sheldon like we have a lot of viewers
and a lot of viewers and the critics
didn't like it and it's so funny how you
people like Louis success now he got
murdered for this shot I remember
[ __ ] killed for pointing hurt it hurt
him they really he was broke after this
show like they really [ __ ] beat up
Louie they were hot yeah they were nasty
yeah Pootie Tang was really tough on him
and then this like he had just been and
he had just done it a pilot before that
st. Louis or something like that
but I mean you know he really really
tried and he I mean this is all his
vision when we did the camera test the
director on the show was like please
tell me you're not gonna shoot it on
video please tell me you're not and he
was like I want to shoot it on video
show looks like [ __ ] [ __ ] and it
looks crazy and it's not right and
they're not doing it right but I mean
and why did he want to shoot it on video
he wanted it to feel like a Norman Lear
show right back from that time when he
was growing up and he had a long
conversation with Norman Lear who's one
of his idols and Norman Lear said you
don't think that I had the option of
film of course I could have filmed my
shows but he chose to shoot his shows on
video and so it was like a warm
comforting thing